what I was about to show you is a um
it's a footnote to the previous lesson
that we just had I didn't make it in
time I could have like crammed in in but
then you would like zero opportunity to
think and pause and ask questions and
after much going on okay now for
Wordsworth this is a brief idea and it's
so overlaps of things you already know
you should be able to stomach it just
one okay now the hair use linear
factorization that's kind of a shortfall
for linear factorization of polynomials
because those polynomials so I'm just
going to if she's in heat morning this
notation here right this is function
notation right that's fine I mean I I
think it's it's a proper to the fact
that I listed by taking notes like
that's actually the mechanism by which I
listen 513 notes I find it very
difficult to the sensor yeah it's more
about meeting I know some people don't
which is okay
now if I asked you to factorize this
okay I can ask you to factorize this but
at least up until now you haven't been
able to do a linear factorization let me
try to explain what that means X cubed
plus X this is my I'm calling a capital
pay for polynomial rather F because not
just a function polynomials all I'm
interested in how far can factorize is
what can you do you can you can take our
next yes
so that would look like this okay now in
the real number world you're finished
that's it
it's factorized right so here's what
matter okay now a factor factorization
just means write it in as a product of
different things and I'm done okay and I
know x squared plus one is not like it's
not simplified then I can't do anything
else to it though like that's as far as
Isis go but if we're in the complex
world
so if I rewrite this now same polynomial
but if I can sit up if I if I cost my
debt a little wider okay so I'm going
write P of Zed so that's my signal that
I'm going to be the conference well is
it cubed plus Z and now I'll specify
this it is a complex number just be case
it was on and be good before now I
actually can go farther further okay
because when I take out my factor of Z
everybody take a seat when I take out my
factor is Ed and I say okay Zed squared
plus 1 I can go further now because I
have more numbers at my disposal right
what is this thing what is this thing
yeah I can write this I can actually
write this as the difference of squares
if I have complex numbers at my disposal
right how am i right this is the
difference of squares well I will write
this and I'll do like several steps here
which might be very obvious to you but
hopefully that will be when you come
back to it you'll be like oh yeah no
it's really if this is the difference of
squares then of course instead of a plus
I need a minus there yeah so I'm going
to write for one takeaway and the number
I'm going to take away is yep okay yes
okay now what if I got here this I mean
we're not used to thinking of everyone
as a square number but it is because we
have more numbers at disposal right so
this is Z times Z squared takeaway what
number do I swear to get negative one
answer fine
so this is actually I squared here and
now I have my difference of squares
right you're happy with that so now it's
obvious that I can factorize further
here is my final factorization okay now
what have I arrived at this is a similar
kind of things what I had before
I have one two three factors instead of
two so what I want to point out to you
what it is here I factorized and in the
real number field that's as far as you
can go okay I have two faculties but you
notice what kinds of factors are they
money this this guy named X that's well
they're all real out there but more
importantly it's Lydia right y equals x
is a straight line okay but x squared
plus 1 is not a straight line it's a
factor but it's not a linear factor in
fact it's a quadratic right only once I
get through complex numbers can I get
down to a truly linear factorization
because complex numbers I'll be able to
factorize anything into complex numbers
right complex numbers is the bottom of
the barrel everywhere or the top of the
mountain all three of these if I let
myself use complex numbers all three of
them can be linear